zach lowther preparing to make his first
major league start and his second
overall major league appearance he made
his big league debut on april 25th
against the oakland a's
and strikes him out so his first batter
as a starter down on strikes that's a
good start for zach lather yeah that's a
good breaking ball too so two fastballs
and this one here hurts your feelings
i'm talking about a real downer evening
starts with a strikeout now here's the
center fielder alex verdugo at the plate
he's gonna line that one into the
outfield for a base set so first red sox
hit of the night comes off the bat of
verdugo second out of the top of the
first inning for xander bogarts
there's a swing and a grounder to short
fielded by galvez sidearms to second for
the force out of verdugo and the first
inning is over so zach's louder puts his
scoreless frame up there garrett
richards one and two yeah no decision
last time out against the texas rangers
went five innings in that game one
earned run
the game before that seven innings
against the mets giving up one earned
run here's cedric mullins
hit hard off the glove and into right
field chavez couldn't bring it in and
cedric mullins on board set by richards
here's the 1-0 mullins goes fastball
high off the glove of vazquez easy
peckings for cedric mullins mullen
started the inning with a base hit and
stole second he advanced the third on a
ground out now here comes dj stewart
there's a base hit in the center field
that'll get a run in
stewart with the rbi mullen scores and
the orioles do take a one-nothing lead
we're underway in the second inning
first walk for zach lauther one out walk
to vasquez send marwyn gonzalez up to
the plate
sock the other way that's headed for the
gap
stewart trying to cut it off out there
eventually gets to it all the way down
to third is vasquez gonzalez sliding in
here comes vasquez as it scampers away
and he comes in
and the red sox have tied it
so tied at one with gonzales at second
and here's hunter renfro
and that's gonna be up the middle for a
base hit
gonzalez rounding third he will score
easily
renfro continues a hot month and a red
sox lead it two to one two down for
chavis who struck out to begin the ball
game
it's that one well deep to left hayes on
the run he leaps can't get it it is out
of here a home run for chavis blasting
away for a two-run shot and his return
to the lineup he put a heck of a swing
on this one and found the seats at
camden yards and the red sox open it up
four to one red zack score four times
and they lead it four to one as we start
the home second galvez will start off
the ending riding an eight-game hitting
streak
fly ball left field it's deep down in
the corner and it is gone freddy galvez
keep that hitting streak alive
home run for freddy and the orioles get
one back number four on the year for
galves third inning in baltimore runners
it first and second with nobody out for
vasquez who walked on five pitches his
first time up and he scored
and that'll be hammered in left center
for a base hit in to score bogarts
sliding hard into third is denver's and
the red sox keep on swinging it now
leading it five to two hit walk hit rbi
for vasquez snouts defers at third
vasquez at second nobody out top of the
third
swing and a miss marwyn gonzalez chases
a curvy set down and here comes brandon
hyde that's going to do it for him
they'll send out for sean armstrong two
down for dalbeck could fly to right his
first time up and he swings and lines
one to left field sinking fast it's a
base hit it should score two
debris crosses the plate vasquez two a
two run single for bobby dalbeck he's
got five rbis in this series and the red
sox lead at seven to two 7-2 red sox in
the third two-way nobody on
one hopper into the shift grabbed by
chavis and shala right clips to first
and
shut down inning
for richards in an easy one after three
7-2 boston and everything's dropping in
the runners are gonna go up to second
and third they're gonna be all loaded up
and now raffy deborah is the only guy in
the lineup who does not have a hit yet
ground ball snatched up by mancini into
second one back to first not in time and
a run comes in rodrigo scores red sox
lead at eight to two jd the third raffi
at first for christian vasquez
and he'll serve that one into left field
for a base hit
martinez in 9-2 boston and another rbi
for christian vasquez tonight the red
sox have been in command of this one a
9-2 lead buying garrett richards already
12 red sox hits there's a curve in there
he got him looking big bender really
good curve tonight there's the first
strikeout for
gary richards and here's galvez
wing and a miss strike three
got him on a breaking ball in the dirt
the first two strikeouts have come
consecutively here and it brings up
frank keel who rounded his short his
first time
up instead a little contact makes the
back end of play throws oh really nice
play
to cut him down at first by garrett
richards hits the deck yeah they finally
went down one two three for the first
time a ball and two strikes to cisco
there's a base hit
there's a big field out there he used it
and he gives the orioles a base hit
snapping a string of seven in a row set
down rio ruiz is next ground ball to the
right side dalbeck has it goes to second
for one bogarts will throw it back to
first and it's in time how did they get
rio ruiz was he walking down the first
base line it's a double play and with
two down here comes cedric mullins
curveball swung on and missed he struck
him out
beautiful stuff for richards an unlikely
turn of a double play that helped but we
go to the six two red sox they've had a
dozen hits so wells walks the first
batter and here comes xander swing
there's the drive to left fee way back
this ball is long gone and inside
fastball was not even in the strike zone
xander turned on it and he hit a bomb
deep to left 11 to two he's having some
month some season so far bottom of the
sixth inning lead off double by the
orioles now it'll send up mancini
another shot down off the glove of
devers again
pays around third he'll score and
mancini in with a double
so two blistering shots off the glove of
third baseman rafael devers and the
orioles at a run they're going to bring
on ramona rios as a pinch hitter
into right field base hit that's going
to get mancini home rbi for urias and
now it's 11 to 3. three hits and a walk
in this inning franco will be the
battery he's gone over two still only
the one man out
that's a hot shot boat ride's a terrific
stab out there onto first the
double play the red sox turn two and one
of their more spectacular double plays
of the season and xander made a
beautiful backhand pick going down to a
knee whirled around and got it over to
chavis one down for ruiz who grounded
the single the left and then bounced
into a three six three double play
caught on and missed he puts away ruiz
for another strikeout his fifth now this
is a beautiful thing his fifth strikeout
and here's mullins
swinging a line right caught on a leap
there by bogarts who's made a couple of
dandy plays why doesn't he do something
tonight and we have a position player
pitching pat valenka is going to come on
and pitch in a seven run game first ball
is put into play left side off the glove
of urias for a base hit
to second for one and that's all they'll
get
the leica delivers this ball is hit in
the air to right
back goes dj stewart makes the catch shy
of the track and they're two away
oh look at this
he would have had him one two three
except for an error
that was quick red sox retired to the
top of the ninth way to go pat valencia
one out away from win number 21.
faces are loaded here and haze the
batter
into right field that's a base hit
franco scores right behind him rio ruiz
and the orioles add a couple it's taylor
coming in with runners on first and
third with two down
swinging and a miss and that's how you
get that done
josh taylor ending it
with a strikeout emphatically and the
red sox went at 11-6 they won the first
two games of this series they out hit
the orioles 15-9.